[Music]
two years ago I was invited as an artist
to participate in an exhibition
commemorating 100 years of Islamic art
in Europe the curator had only one
condition I had to use the Arabic script
for my art work now as an artist a woman
an Arab or a human being living in the
world in 2010 I only had one thing to
say I wanted to say no and in Arabic to
say no we say no and a thousand times no
so I decided to look for a thousand
different nose on everything ever
produced under Islamic or Arab patronage
in the past 1400 years from Spain to the
borders of China I collected my findings
and a book placed them chronologically
stating the name the patron the medium
and the date now the book sat on a small
shelf next to the installation which
stood three by seven meters in Munich
Germany in September of 2010 now in
January 2011 the Revolution started and
life stopped for eighteen days and on
the 12th of February we naively
celebrated on the streets of Cairo
believing that the revolution had
succeeded nine months later I found
myself spraying messages in Tahrir
Square the reason for this act was this
image that I saw in my newsfeed I did
not feel that I could live in a city
where people were being killed and
thrown like garbage on the street so I
took one know of a tombstone from the
Islamic Museum in Cairo and I added a
message to it no to military rule and I
started spraying that occur on the
streets in Cairo but that led to a
series of no coming out of the book like
a munition and adding messages to them
and I started spraying them on the walls
so I'll be sharing some of these nose
with you note a new Pharaoh because
whoever comes next should understand
that you will never be ruled by another
dictator no to violence romneyís some
came to the Herald on the second day of
the Revolution and he sat there with his
guitar singing one month after Mubarak
stepped down this was his reward no -
blinding heroes
Ahmed Herrera lost his right eye on the
28th of January and he lost his left eye
on the 19th of November by two different
snipers no to killing in this case no to
killing men of religion because she can
imagine a life that was shot on December
16th during a demonstration leaving
behind three orphans and the widow not
two burning books the Institute of Egypt
was burned on December 17th a huge
cultural loss no to stripping the people
and the blue bra is to remind us of our
shame as a nation when we allow a veiled
woman to be stripped and beaten on the
street and the footprint reads long live
a peaceful revolution because we will
never retaliate with violence no to
barrier walls On February 5th concrete
roadblocks were set up in Cairo to
protect the Ministry of Defense from
protesters now speaking of words I want
to share with you the story of one wall
in Cairo a group of artists decided to
paint a life-size tank on a wall it's
one to one in front of this tank there's
a man on a bicycle with a bread basket
on his head to any passerby there's no
problem with this visual after acts of
violence
another artist came painted blood
protesters being run over by the tank
demonstrators and the message that read
starting tomorrow I wear the new face
the face of every martyr I exist
authority comes paints the worldwide
leaves the tank and adds a message army
and people one-hand Egypt for Egyptians
now the artist comes paints the head of
the military as a monster eating a
maiden in a river of blood in front of
the tank authority comes paints the
worldwide leaves the tank leaves the
food and throws a bucket of black paint
just to hide the face of the monster
so I come with my stencils and I spray
them on the suit on the tank and on the
whole world and this is how it stands
today until further notice now I want to
leave you with a final with a final know
I found me rue de scribbled on a piece
of paper in a field hospital and the
idea and I decided to take a now of
Mameluke mausoleum in Cairo the message
reads yum Kanaka Anton has renewed like
in a colitis Tatiana Herrera via you can
crush the flowers but you can't delay
spring
[Applause]